después de una tormenta lily mide la
profundidad de varios charcos en su
patio los registros de sus mediciones
fueron los siguientes y aquí tenemos los
diferentes cargos y sus medidas en
centímetros y nos preguntan por cuánto
supera la profundidad del charco debajo
del columpio a la profundidad del charco
de la banqueta pausa el vídeo e intenta
encontrar la respuesta
bueno nos dicen por cuánto supera la
profundidad del charco debajo del
columpio ok es esta profundidad que
tengo aquí un entero un cuarto más
centímetros debajo del columpio a la
profundidad del charco de la banqueta
déjame ponerlo con otro color del charco
de la banqueta que es este de aquí dos
cuartos de centímetros por lo tanto
podemos restarle dos cuartos a un entero
un cuarto para obtener la respuesta
podemos escribir un entero un cuarto ya
esto quitarle dos cuartos y tal vez
podríamos intentar hacer esta resta de
esta refracción con fracción y entero
con entero pero inmediatamente nos damos
cuenta de un problema
cuarto es una fracción más grande que un
cuarto así que como encontramos esta
resta
bueno la clave es recordar que un entero
lo podemos escribir como una fracción un
entero un cuarto es lo mismo que bueno
que uno más un cuarto y ahora una forma
de escribir al 1 en términos de cuartos
es cuatro cuartos entonces tengo que
esto va a ser igual a cuatro cuartos 1
enteros 4 cuartos más un cuarto más un
cuarto
y esto va a ser bueno 41 55 cuartos por
lo tanto puedo ver a este un entero un
cuarto como cinco cuartos ya esto hay
que quitarle dos cuartos entonces a esto
de aquí le voy a quitar dos cuartos y
esto es muy fácil de hacer porque si
tienes cinco de algo y le restas dos de
ese mismo algo entonces me quedaré con
tres de ese algo en este caso es tres
cuartos por lo tanto si quiere responder
la pregunta por cuánto supera la
profundidad del charco debajo del
columpio a la profundidad del charco de
la banqueta la respuesta será tres
cuartos de centímetro
ahora otra forma de realizar este mismo
ejercicio es restar estos dos cuartos de
un entero un cuarto pero podemos
visualizarlo si veo a este un entero un
cuarto común bueno uno es un entero así
que lo pondré así
y también voy a dibujar otro entero para
dividirlo en cuatro partes iguales así
que aquí voy a tener cuatro partes
iguales y de estas cuatro partes iguales
voy a tomar una de ellas por lo tanto
tengo ahora un entero con un cuarto todo
sombreado ya esto hay que quitarle dos
cuartos bueno primero dijimos cómo
podemos quitarle dos cuartos a este
pedacito de un cuarto de aquí y
concluimos que no podíamos hacerlo
después recordamos que este entero lo
podemos ver como cuatro cuartos es decir
lo podemos dividir en cuatro partes
iguales y ahora tenemos uno dos tres
cuatro cinco cuartos entonces a estos
cinco cuartos ahora sí le puedo hacer la
resta y quitarle dos cuartos entonces
voy a quitar este cuarto de aquí y voy a
quitar este cuarto de aquí y me voy a
quedar con
estos tres cuartos que son mi respuesta
así que hemos acabado seguiremos en el
siguiente vídeo